[Music]
where's the board we don't see this is a
podcast okay so sitting down with my
most brilliant legendary iconic
showrunners in television history a
little show called 24. change television
fair to say change television I you
don't don't ask are you allowed to agree
with that uh I I will say it did and I I
will because I didn't create the show I
I did I did run it in its last four
years but Joel and Bob Joel surname and
Bob Cochran who actually are neighbors
of yours
um created the show and we're and our
great friends and I will say because I
am not celebrating my own creation uh it
did it changed things and it really was
I think one of the first binge TV
experiences
um and uh and it's it is it was a great
great time Homeland no big whoop there
we go and also I knew I think I knew you
were on X-Files on some level but the
first four years that was like where I
really cut my teeth can I ask you crazy
questions because that's what this
podcast is it's tangents it's Controlled
Chaos this is the opposite of the
brilliant surgical television that you
make no but I I think I'm a Cubist
thinker I don't have my wife here I'd
jump from one sentence to the third
where do you stand on Aliens because I
have a theory
I am just I'm just such a skeptic well
actually I'm becoming less and less so
but I think they're here and I think
they're octopuses
very possible having seen my octopus
teacher I've stopped eating them unless
somebody has ordered them and it's it's
already dead
but I generally don't order it right
right but it was I had a niece who's
like who well before my octopus teacher
was like oh you was a marine biologist
and My Worship strained good all and
made me feel sufficiently bad that's
about where I've drawn my line I said
once uh but once octopi started writing
poetries when I'll really like stopping
I'll really stop eating right remember I
mean I'm not really a big fan of poetry
so that's okay
I've had a really good script yeah right
right so there you go I kind of think
you're an alien I think some of the
smartest smartest people I'm like I meet
someone like you I travel all over the
world you're not like anyone else I'm
not that smart I just I'm smart enough
to know how dumb I am which I think is
that's what all brilliant people say I
don't think it's I don't well I don't
think it's I know people who are a lot a
lot smarter than me maybe you know I
think I'm good I'm a good I hope I'm a
good listener I'm a good synthesizer and
and but it's an Intel you know
intelligence is a very elusive thing
isn't it there are people we both have
met who are you know I'm sure they're
lobe has got like you know their Quant
lobe is bigger than mine I understand
some things I think I understand human
nature it feels like and that's kind of
what you understand it I think without
judging it which I think is a form of
emotional intelligence I do think that
and it vexes people to like not assign
some binary good and evil right and
wrong I mean life is very complicated
and people are very complicated and and
morality is so conditional it just is
and and good people and I think that the
smartest people or the the ones that you
know as I think about Darwinism and how
like you know right now you know it's
like survival of the fittest or how you
know intelligence is evolving I think
the most intelligent people and the ones
that are going to survive that are the
fittest are the ones that can hold space
that two things can be true at once have
you ever a Siri who who's smarter uh
Siri or or Alexa have you ever gotten
them what I really like is the civility
of AI that they're actually polite they
say I can't judge other I'm more like
why was Siri and Alexa why did they both
have to be named women's names because
the first iteration is always going to
have glitches is it's always so people
like fucking Siri shut up Siri like it
just has become another annoying you
know what I think you're I think that's
a really good point Alexa shut up Alexa
she got it wrong oh stupid woman
it's like crazy and then we name cars
after women so when they break down
we're like oh she's broken again like I
just want to name neutral name it a guy
Joe ask Joe yes let's start our own but
think about it if it was if if Alexa was
named Joe and it screwed up all the time
he's like Joe pull it together you crazy
guys
stupid bitch shut up stop recording me
like that's the other thing because it's
like this technology we're all very
suspicious of on some level and paranoid
it's recording me whatever so now it's
just like Alexis recording it's just
like another woman that's being
secretive and trying to trick you or
something I'm like this is not helping
the stereotypes
I'm with you you know it's like like uh
GPS like I'm always like can you make
this a man so that is I I haven't done
it did she does GPS when it's like take
a look at GPS it's a woman I'm like
bitch what do you know you can't fucking
drive like I just simply like I do the
English accent because it comes out with
a little more Authority I I I I tend to
do that that's really smart yeah yeah
but yeah so I'm just I'm more obsessed
with that why don't we think that people
with British accents are smart like what
is that what is that do they get like an
extra 50 IQ points my aunt used to work
in customer service at Orvis she has
southern accent in customer service you
can only get to a certain level
promotion wise and they're always at the
top top it's going to be someone with an
English accent because all people assume
they're smarter right so if they're like
I have a problem with my thing and
you're like why don't you just check to
see everyone's like you're an idiot let
me talk to your manager people don't
have a lot of patience for southern
accent that's a real thing but English
I'm like English accent smarter why you
guys you guys pay taxes to people that
were born into Power you're not smarter
than us right yeah like I'm like I'm not
but then as you get North or North then
you start talking about clam chowder and
it gets it goes bad again there's the
bandwidth of the elite that is sure like
in DC and Connecticut
accent it is fascinating I come from
West Virginia Virginia and then I came
to LA and I'm like auditioning did you
have it did you have a little bit of an
accent yeah that a little bit and then
but I want to totally get ready I'm from
Long Island I I don't know I didn't
intentionally drop mine I think it just
kind of do you ever find that it comes
out more when you're around I don't know
why I actually don't know why I don't
have I don't sound like my brothers or
my mother I don't know why I went in to
perform in the Hamptons and in the South
when you find a tick on you you pull it
out you bite its head off you pull it
out you burn it you're fine right in the
Hamptons where the richest most powerful
people in the world are you find a tick
on you and you're not it's a 9-1-1 why
are we what are we doing coming around I
think they're making tacos now out of
them like crickets and ticks in the
Hamptons
but like do you like it's amazing to me
the smartest people in the world they go
to The Hamptons to surround themselves
with deadly bugs right what's that every
couple years a great Avril Lavigne we
lost her for four years to Lyme disease
right right this is crazy to me yeah no
one's talking about everyone's talking
about coven I'm talking about lines they
can't diagnose it they don't know quite
well yeah it's also tricky because most
people that are in the Hamptons that
have Lyme disease are also on like Xanax
and all sorts of other pills
did you take
this in it's hard to the lady let's not
blame the ticks for your drug problems
the show is sponsored by better help
betterhelp is a damn miracle I know you
guys know this but I've been um reunited
with uh my sibling my sister I have an
older sister she's 13 months older than
me which means yes I'm an accident
her coming back in my life has been just
when I thought you know I was nailing it
uh on the mental health fronts
um us coming back together has been
so healing in so many ways and so it's
bringing up a lot like of stuff that I
was completely in denial about like
we're also doing two sessions a week
together so that when we're talking
about this really brutal fraught stuff
we have someone there to kind of mediate
it's just so helpful to have a therapist
there as we're healing our relationship
just to help navigate it and I'm
doubling down on therapy just when I
thought I graduated mental health I'm
back I'm back to being a Freshman uh so
couldn't recommend it enough if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge so
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com Whitney today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp hellp.com Whitney
do you ever catch yourself going like I
really want to make this point I do it I
catch myself all the time when I'm doing
stand up I have to you know write the
joke I do the joke and then I sort of
feel myself going like oh like I'm I'm
writing this joke right now which is
very tricky that I'm teaching on stage
it's yeah sure it's about how um you
know as a comedian I never want to be
didactic or lecturing anyone comedians
you know and and actors a couple years
ago remember when actors started
lecturing Americans on like how to vote
and live from their mansions that was
awkward I just was crazy you know that
actors were like you guys need to stay
inside people like we work at grocery
stores like we can't stay inside what do
you mean me staying inside I live with
my grandparents my aunt like 12 people
live in an apartment just being so out
of touch and I think that who are we to
say like I think that we live in a
country where it's like right now we're
like I should be able to say whatever I
want but you shouldn't that's where what
we've gotten into I really believe we
have gotten into a bit of a mess and and
for me this show was a little bit uh an
opportunity to sort of address that I
want to say address it and I'm going
back to your point of do you ever like
find yourself wanting to make a point
and and and and I kind of would say no
because I just go mine because I have to
entertain
I think I think again whether and
whether it's 24 or or Homeland or this
show I think what I find interesting
about this life is that there aren't
right choices and wrong choices there's
often the least bad of two choices and
and putting characters into a corner
like that is like catnip to me and I I
just because you know you get the you
know I hate to use words like what a you
know a privilege it is to do it but it
is fun to take this sort of safe free
exercise of what would I do and how
would I act and I think that's what the
best thing is what you guys do to you
hold up a mirror you make a c and think
about things a little bit differently
than we did when before I stepped into
your show I hope this show does kind of
the same thing and you do this selfless
thing and the work that you do and with
with accused especially like you know
it's almost like I like to say like you
know as a comedian you know we're like
the referees of culture we don't take
sides right right we go this kind of has
a point this kind of has a point we're
kind of like we're gonna show you all
the Angles and then you make the
decision hello that's I mean that and
that what a gift we're going to hold it
up to you to be able to pick the side
that you want right so we're going to be
the criminal defense and then we're
gonna you know we're gonna defend both
sides I always say you know comedy as
you say something that's not true and
then you prove it you know just as a
thought exercise right you know like let
me just play Devil's Advocate whatever
it is you know no one feels like they
can do that anymore just for the sake of
going let me be Devil's Advocate let me
go like like Trump was the best
president we've ever had let me just
make that argument just to make sure
we're right about the other thing that's
right and by the way that's actually an
exercise in rhetoric and empathy and
debate is taking the other side that
it's actually it rewires you when you
actually have to uh take something that
you think you you know or take a side
that you reflexively don't take and then
animate it and lean into it and and
that's right look I'd like to do that
with even you know the bad guys on all
our characters I you have to love all
your characters you have to feel like no
one wakes up in the morning and goes I'm
a bad guy you know I want to destroy the
world but see Comics we're already like
that like you know I'll do that
intuitively and I'm also a person that
has done a lot of things I'm not proud
of you know for reasons that I am proud
of you know and I go like I actually
stand behind that you know like I you
know this was the consequence and you
know but my intention my impact weren't
Congress and I regret the impact but
like my heart was in the right place and
and mistakes bring us to the next moment
and you can and no one wants to watch
moral perfection no one wants to watch
people that you know you know it's just
it's just not entertaining it's not
funny and it's not interesting can I
throw a theory at you which is uh gonna
uh tie in why I'm bringing up aliens I
think you know I'm obsessed with Terror
management Theory you know Ernest Becker
of like how we're the only human we're
the only species that knows we're gonna
die so we have this existential dread
and in order to like uh is it anadonia
anadonia I mean that's anadonia being
um and I think this is true right that
Annie Hall was initially called anadonia
and anadonia being the condition of I I
I'm sure I have this but you can't enjoy
the present because you're too busy
grieving it being over it sounds cliche
but being in the moment is just a it's a
hard thing to do
um
what do you do
to feel it well you're somewhere and
you're already mourning it's it's being
over I just I you know to me to say you
know I think that we're both uh
documentors like we're both the kind of
people they're like we gotta get you
know when I'm like let me record this
let me take pictures like let me take
video that does help me yeah you you
have it you've captured some and then
I'll appreciate it a ton later I used to
be a collector of like Matt when I was a
kid I was so nostalgic already
anticipating exactly I had a a candy tin
filled with every every movie I watched
that that moved me like you know the 11
o'clock or midnight movie I would cut
out the TV guide and put it in in a box
just wanting to reclaim it and keep it
and I'm uh
you are you are I got you the moment I
walked into your house I did I said
nothing gets thrown away everything you
know and I also like to share with other
people I think we're the kind of people
who if we you know have a thought or we
have a notion we have this urge to like
share it with other people you know I
don't I I was the youngest I was you
know how many years a mistake I well I'm
13 months younger than my sister so I've
obviously an accident I was the youngest
in my family I had to fit into an
already established system of an alcohol
calm so it was a lot of like like look
at this look at this look at me and it's
very hard to get people's attention and
then I sort of you did end up at luck I
I remember my dad would watch uh
television you would watch Three's
Company and I couldn't get his attention
and my mom I couldn't get her attention
either and I remember looking at the TV
screen going I need to get all that's
how I I need to get on that box
I remember I had by the way I had a
similar I mean the TV was always on in
my own uniquely dysfunctional family and
I was like I don't know what it was
about that box it wasn't even like it
wasn't movies I liked movies but I loved
TV I loved this thing and I I couldn't
even imagine how one did it
and but you know the relationship I love
doing commercials like because that was
of course because that's the home I
wanted to be in I mean commercials was
and also commercials used to be like
closer to the Brady Bunch than it was to
my own family like I mean they really
you live with those and you you know and
if you grow up poor without money you
look at remember when commercials were
like a minute and a half long yeah it
used to be long you know and I used to
be like I want to live in that house I
want to be there so actually my first
Dream as an actress was to be in
commercials looking at the TV and being
like that's the life I want to be in you
know at a very young age and and needing
to escape and then needing to entertain
myself you know so I spent so much time
in my imagination as a kid and it's how
I coped and I you know repressed a lot
disassociated a lot I I you know you're
the first person that I um
felt safe enough to for lack of a better
word like undis associate with like to a
lot of the stuff that I disassociate as
a child sexual abuse
um Etc that I use to anesthetize with
fantasy I would like make up stories I
used to this is so embarrassing but we
all have some form of this I wasn't a
dancing in the mirror kind of girl like
making view I would have sit-down
interviews with myself and like pretend
I was being interviewed by Oprah like I
would write out interviews as if I was
being I totally get you because I
dreamed and would imagine talking to
Johnny Carson I would I mean it was it
was it was and and it was clearly I mean
again in my own situation it was like it
was it was it was um it was kind of just
it was a way of legitimizing your
existence this like I'm uh you know
whether whatever whatever shame
invisibility uh need for attention all
conflated into like I'm gonna be the
youngest novelist on The Tonight Show
and I and I wrote a novel in eighth
grade because I was going to be talking
to Johnny and it was crazy that's so
what like that I'm obsessed with just
our um that Warrior Spirit of the inner
Triumph of because I think that that the
the the sort of subconscious
um motive there is like me going like I
know I'm interesting like my parents
might not get it but like well I know
there's also race I have something
special I think I I yes I mean obviously
all of us who do this have the kind of
to marry it I think we actually have
something to say that's worth saying
which everyone does it's just a matter
of fact all you need is that delusional
confidence but it requires a delusional
confidence to do this because there'll
be a thousand people to tell you why
it's not gonna which is fascinating in
the episode uh that Billy Porter
directed about drag queens you know I
had Trixie Mattel on and it was
explaining like what is our obsession
with drag queens why are they so
entertaining why are they so fun to
watch and then why are they so loathed
by the people that load them and she's
her theory on it and which is you know I
believe is the case which is um people
are signing up to see someone with
delusional confidence it is so
entertaining to watch someone with
delusional I need someone who's going to
be in charge who doesn't give a shit
right talking to you about this I think
that for me you know this show and I'm
sorry to put so much on you and I really
tried to like you know not fill you in
on all this while we were working
because I didn't want it to feel like
unnecessarily heavy and acting is still
acting it's a craft it's a skill it's a
you know we go to work and then you know
when we're wrapped we should you know be
done with work um because I think that
you know I'm I don't want to glamorize
like emotional cutting or using acting
as a way to you know hurt yourself but
for me I I you know my whole life I have
disassociated the sexual abuse that
happened to me happily so it worked
denial you know the the
um listening to Jill Hennessy talk about
the first episode of accused which
I I know this is a show I was on the set
I saw the cast and crew I was watching
it right here on my laptop before
checklist came in it wasn't even in a
cinematic way I was
I was jumping I was literally I had to
like go for I was pacing I was like oh
my God like I was on these guys no it's
it's a I had a friend he doesn't watch
TV but he said I I couldn't stop
watching it and with you know anxiety I
was so frustrated stressed like anxious
and you know it it's so rare that
entertainers can be entertained it's so
rare that because you see the magic
trick and you you're aware of the sort
of bustman's holiday at all but this was
um it's great I'm so happy to hear that
and it is such but I felt the same way
about your episode I really felt like
you know it was and again I got to see
what's interesting about it is my place
in the in the you know we I was not on
the set with you with you all and I was
um and so I inherited this film and this
idea that I that again was I had to
shape a lot of it and I called you Oz
you were like The Wizard of Oz like he
because we were shooting in Toronto just
to get granular uh uh you know it's a my
episode
um which many of you have seen is uh you
know it's a sexual assault episode it's
a very rape scene covet is happening
we're all in masks it's a very intense
drama we're in Toronto and then you were
back in L.A sort of on an iPad kind of
giving direction sort of from well just
just I just want to see yeah but so it's
hard for us we didn't get to really
connect during so we did before though
quite a bit and you had and you and
again you're what was wonderful and was
such a gift is that the time we had to
develop the script your input was so I
mean with sonay who you know who wrote
it and Julie who directed it I just felt
like it was I and all three of you came
at it so clearly I got to be kind of
Midwife this thing in a way
um so it was somewhere between a midwife
and Oz I suppose well may I ask you
because um I'm just going to start by
saying you know there's an obsession
with female comedians right now there's
always kind of been one
um you know uh we always joke we're the
most hated species of human on the
planet because you know it's like you
know we have the audacity to go on stage
and the courage to go on stage and say
I'm a piece of shit you know it's like
I'm a piece of shit in the center of the
universe and we charge people money to
hear us talk for two hours with no
chance of having sex with us at the end
but you know fans only you know I
entered into this with a very clear idea
of knowing like I'm going to be hated by
a lot of people for reasons that have
nothing to do with me and I'm going to
be loved by a lot of people for me for
doing this part no just being a female
comedian in general because I have
imposter syndrome too if you guys are
like how dare you think you do I'm the
same way I'm like I don't like how dare
I we're you know we I vacillate from you
know uh having just because you have
confidence it doesn't mean you have
self-esteem those are two different
things so I've really you know a lot of
people think I have very high
self-esteem you have when you have very
high confidence so then I think people
go like oh you're not confused yeah
they're not well because people go
you're a female comic you're strong you
have high self-esteem when in fact you
actually just had confidence so it's a
lot of incredibly damaged people doing
this thing to get attention because they
were broken and then people just
breaking them re-breaking them breaking
the shards you know so it's sort of
um it's kind of masochism too it's like
it's like an exercise it's also if you
come from severe abuse it's it's nothing
yeah yeah you can't touch it because I
hate myself so much more than you I mean
when the comments like when my sitcom
came out and everyone was like you know
you're a whore you're not funny or this
and I'm like I agree with all of them is
that the best you guys I I always tell I
tell Executives I hate when I hand
something in I hate it more than you'll
ever yeah
you know there's a fascination with
female comedians right now but I think
that the business is kind of scared of
us hates us unclear I love marvelous Mrs
maisel it's brilliant I love hacks it's
brilliant but there's no female
comedians involved in it like they they
don't let us in the writers I'm not
saying me there's just tons of great
ones that could be in the writer's room
or be and it is actors and so when you
came to me with this a role that was
playing a female comedian I was already
so blindsided that you decided to come
to an actual female comedian can I just
ask the process and I you can't install
me or hurt me if you offered it no no
you were literally the first last and
only and so it was it was when you were
talking right now it reminded me of even
Claire and Homeland like literally we
called Claire Claire uh when we wrote it
just because because I wrote it with
Alex and I wrote it together we just
wanted to have somebody in mind she had
just done
um this Temple Grand in HBO yeah and
like you were like at your Clarion was
the description was something was
fiercely smart a little bit broken and
you know of a woman of a certain age you
know beautiful sexual but yeah but in a
way that it meant so we had this
consolation of of of of of of characters
you were like it so when you responded
it was like wow that was you know now we
thought about it very clearly and the
moment your name came up it was like you
are you know it was perfect and the fact
that you responded the way you did was
but you had no reason to know that I
could do drama here's a clip
I'm a comedian we said crazy things
been assaulted
be smiling it will ruin both of our
Lives to move on stop him before he hurt
other women
this is the great thing about being my
age and having done Homeland and all
those other ones is at this point I can
just take chances and those chances have
been amazingly Pro uh you know
profitable and creatively profitable
yeah like Billy Porter and Marley I mean
it's so great to just go let's just go
for it because at this point in this
moment you have nothing to prove
anything to prove and just your instinct
and my instinct was this is going to be
fantastic and also I don't think like
you say on me again not agreeing with
you or disagree on nasal or on Hacks
it had there is something you know when
someone's acting like a comedian and
when someone is a community it's like
playing an athlete in the show it is
it's like when you see an actor playing
basketball it just doesn't feel like
Michael Jordan yeah you're not I mean
Will Smith did an okayle uh but yeah
every now and then you'll get a uh
situation with Jamie Foxx playing Rey
where he is in position and you're like
you know that was great yeah that's that
was that's amazing but yeah by and large
it's hard and this was it was really I
knew that we needed to see
and hear this person do her thing
because also she's a woman of a certain
age too who is like it was important
that she actually did find her voice
that she had this dream that you and I
both identified but that she hadn't made
it and we all know about being with
people who are in our creative field who
had some success who've had no success
and also how do we what do we do in
those moments and that desperation but
the empathy of this character and and
feeling for her and then sort of
animating well yeah she has slept with
everybody she has it she does drink too
much but she's also really good and what
was brilliant about your contribute your
country was profound was I need to make
her comedy
not me for first of all Not Me Whitney
so it was just a great process from the
beginning you know to the end I mean I'm
glad you enjoyed it because I was
terrified because I'm kidding you know
because anyone I knew was great when you
actually first of all thank you know
again you put in so much extra credit
like If This Were a test you'd have got
you know 105 because you did that comedy
you know you you uh filmed a set with
Brenda Kramer right and I remember I was
at an airport I was traveling and I put
in my earpods and I and I just stopped
and I started smiling and then I started
laughing and I was like I this character
just came alive because you did the work
I can't even imagine how much I mean I I
I someone who doesn't do that I just I
just felt the effort and I felt the care
and I felt the detail of her comedy and
you made this character before we
started shooting I mean so that was
amazing and I I mean and you let us use
a little bit in the promos but man it's
anyway it was great it's well for me I'm
just so like grateful number one it's
you know I get offered drama you know
kind of quite a bit bit but it's the you
know when I look at the great Comedians
and I admire you know that did drama
dramatic turns Robin Williams and Jim
Carrey and you're like well it always
blows everyone's mind that comedians are
great at drama when you're like what
well that's what you do I mean hello
it's like what um I'm Mickey Rourke said
in an interview once that um I think I
said to you uh maybe in our first uh
Zoom meeting where everyone was so blown
away that Mickey Rourke was uh in the
wrestler his performance of where he was
able to be so raw and emotional and one
of the reporters was like uh how were
you able to cry so easily uh in this
movie and he just went well I'm always
about to cry you know so it's not about
starting crying it's about stop stop
crying and I think that on this
production I knew that was maybe going
to be more of it because I was like I'm
gonna sort of open this arsenal of pain
that I've repressed and then this is the
project that deserves it like this is
the project I'm gonna give it to yeah
well you did you really brought it and
you feel it you feel the energy of it in
the performances and in the whole um
yeah because I mean I think that that I
come from like this traditional sort of
acting craft where it's like very
technical and you've got your images and
you've got this and I think for this
character like I just she needed to be
so feral yeah and so sloppy and messy
that I try to kind of even undo all my
acting training to just in well do you
remember I mean just these details again
I think they're small but I think
they're everything because I think um
you know remember your the the Wardrobe
the costume uh uh was like you're
fishing at stockings and you're and
you're too short bright orange thing we
had to fight together and this is again
one of the good things about being by
the way I didn't know a ton about that
fight but this is also can I say another
thing about this just like inside gossip
for us which is you know taking on a
role where a character gets like
brutally raped you know all the people
on the set that the 200 other people
that make the show happen you know have
their own experiences with this right
and this is the first time I've ever
walked into a set where
everyone from wardrobe to makeup to has
a sort of I could tell they have
experience in some way or have family
who have experience and everyone cared
so much about this character and what
was being said and I've never seen you
know wardrobe makeup hair be so like
well no she she needs to come off sexy
so that the audience thinks she was
asking for it and it's you know it was
amazing to watch and I felt almost like
you know this surrender of everyone else
working through me like I normally would
have a pretty strong point of view about
wardrobe or whatever because usually
they just ask you to but everyone had
such specific I came in with a very um
uh as you said like you know
premeditated of who the character was it
was clear everyone had been thinking
about this for a long time and wanted so
badly well this is this team I mean you
know from you know Jeremy uh the the the
creative team now down there really
really when I interviewed every one of
them they were really got what the show
was about and what it was trying to do
so the fact that every Department Kendra
and wardrobe and Elisa in in production
design ever thought so carefully in in
the 360 kind of holistic way about what
this story was about and what we were
doing and but usually people just go
like I'm not gonna be able to get my
idea in any way so I'm just gonna throw
in everyone was this they were like this
is the hill I'm gonna die on in a way
and so I was kind of like walking in
going like because it was like well
these two bracelets and you know choker
so this was again a woman that got you
know sexually assaulted and it's so rare
that any of us in this business get to
make something about a woman who's
unlikable because usually the note is
she's not likable we need her to be more
like or even or even like like oh I
don't I Network executive don't like
that orange shirt uh thing I go well
you're not wearing it like it's like
this is like uh Brenda but then to me I
want so badly to not have any kind of
fissure with you or the network but the
fact that you guys we were on the same
page the whole time but I was like this
my thing is the fact that you don't like
it is the exact reason I know I mean why
is it so hard for people to recognize
that we are not these characters you
talk about the people holding yeah
competing um competing thoughts in the
brain at the same time it's very hard
that's what you want the audience to
feel oh what's that shirt why is she
wearing that right so that then when she
sexually assaulted you're sort of in
that distance like well and then holding
up the mirror to oh I think she deserved
that sexual assault because she was
wearing fishnets what's going on with me
that whose voice is that where did I get
conditioned to think that way you know
and we really pull back even further I
mean it is it is about rape it is about
all those things but then it's also
about the power we now have as
individuals with this thing to tweak
something yeah for the sort of
accelerant of our Rage of our grievances
yeah and the and and what what happens
when someone who's going to be on the
other end of it because it really is I
think a surprising where this episode
goes it's and it's not just about that
it's about what do we do because there's
also this character of like playing
someone that I've worked so so hard to
not be you know like this someone that
is reckless someone that is sort of you
know blows up their own life someone
that just you know doesn't measure twice
cut once before they speak someone who's
just like you know emotionally very
sloppy you know desperate and gives off
an air of desperation you know it's like
you come to this business I had no
Connections in this business I came in
just like I'm gonna be an actress you
know and I would walk into rooms in my
first job it was a show called punked on
MTV which was a prank show remember that
Ashton Kutcher did yeah and then started
doing stand-up and then um did you just
end up in uh um no I did I was at Penn
Communications film at Annenberg and
then uh film major which I want to get
to the film that changed my life the
most and a big part of why I wanted to
um do this part or had The Bravery to do
it because something that a lot of
people don't know about me is like I get
scared too I know it's like I go in
front of thousands of people and
everyone's biggest fear is public
speaking but so to me one of the
scariest things is number one sitting
across from you know someone like you
making eye contact with no audience
right you're doing fine and thank you
and being on a set with a bunch of
people where I have to be very private
and public so one of my biggest fears
about this was going in and going I'm
usually the gregarious person on set
people think of me as a comedian if I go
in and really need to sort of claim my
space and time between takes because
it's so emotionally draining to do a
drama like this and you're working for
so long it's my instinct to like want to
hang out with the crew and build another
big part of why I wanted to do
television is going to come from a
dysfunctional you get to have a family
yeah it's like Camp it is you get to
meet all these incredible artists that
do these incredible things and you walk
into the set and you're like I just want
to like know how they did the
Prosthetics and how they put the wig on
it's like it's like a it's a we're the
freaks it's the coolest thing ever but
then going okay I'm gonna be for three
weeks you know playing this part I need
to make a positive contribution to my
future self and make sure that I'm not
you know getting so
um tight with the crew that one day when
I need to come in and do the rape scene
I don't feel like I'm being rude because
I've established that I'm really social
and uh gregarious that was my own code
pendants I had to deal with and then I
had to deal with okay they might think
I'm a bitch they might think I'm aloof
but I just really like have to put the
work first and I would just kind of like
hide in the corner with my headphones
and that was like a hard thing for me
you know to do because I always want to
make sure everyone else is comfortable
and you know whatever so that was you
know uh very challenging for me because
I was so afraid that like for lack of
better like Whitney was gonna take over
like my mannerisms were gonna start
taking over because for me when I do
stand up or when I'm you know I very
quickly can go into my thing and it's so
interesting biggest nightmare was just
the muscle memory of having a microphone
in front of me and I the choice of
having her keep the microphone on the
stand I never keep the microphone on the
stand when I perform I haven't performed
with the microphone so that was a very
specific choice I needed to make because
if I grab a microphone in a way that's
like you know too skilled it wouldn't
feel like her so I it's it's weird too
it's fantastic it's like it's like um
it's like you can't it's hard to pretend
you're not as good at something as you
are unless you're like really active
Muhammad only missing a punch right
that's exactly it so totally so it was
actually like really hard for me to be
worse and stand up than I am and it was
so frustrating to be like I know that's
how good you are because I think
Brenda's great well because I do think
that there was I think that was that
fine line because I do think she there
and again I don't know if it was
intentional but I thought her her her
bit was really fun it's really funny but
funny light but she's a little bit she's
like it could have been tighter it could
have been punchier for me because I was
like okay playing someone that's
inebriated and and I because there's
something so magical about this because
I was able to sublimate all the the you
know when art is at its best uh I think
you're able to sublimate all of the
negative things that happen to you and
alchemize it into something great that
other people can heal from or be
entertained from and to be able to go
like oh all of that growing up around
alcoholism wasn't for nothing because I
was able to observe alcoholics so much
and one of my uh uh ends with Brenda
being an alcohol are being drunk is you
always you know if you're people that
drink they always think they're a little
quieter than they are they always think
their joke went over a little better
than it did so it was more in the
silences of she she uh let room for
laughter a little longer than it needed
to be she thought she was killing harder
than she was so it wasn't so much of the
jokes weren't uh good it's just that she
was like I totally she heard an Applause
break when it was really just a
smattering of laughs it was more like
that moment afterwards of like nailed it
right you know but there were some great
details too like you know when Zeke
takes a picture of you guys are you
gonna post that I mean those details are
so like fantastic and and and even just
looking at him when looking at him
watching him watch you was like like you
know that was just so great I've worked
so hard to not give off a desperate
energy because you're not gonna when you
start in this business and want to be an
actor you're desperate I was desperate I
had seven dollars for seven years I
would go into rooms like I yeah but by
the way add to it though and I think
this is like makes all the difference in
the world that was when you were 20
something yeah now Brenda's 30-something
and I see that more than ever I see
recently divorced moms that are trying
to become influencers at 42 that are
like if this is still my shot I see you
know friends of mine grown men that are
obsessed with Joe Rogan that are that
are that are doing the burpees and the
steam and the sauna I'm like do you
think you're getting drafted do you
think it's still gonna happen for you
you know I think I know I believe me I I
I I yeah I think we could all like
relate to like like that cringy energy
and I think that I just want to hold
like like lean into that because I've
had it and I think that it was like
everything I don't want to be I get it
but also too did you feel like Brenda
had she had Zeke taking her on tour and
I kind of felt like she found a voice
too like I mean this is this is what I I
sense because there is kind of you know
you this was 25 20 years of craft that
you that you found your voice I think
what she says I I took me a minute but I
got there but I think that the thing
that is really important with hers is
even if you've taken 20 years so I've
taken 20 years but I've done it without
drinking if you're drinking you're
slowing yourself down I see it all the
time some of the most talented people
they're drinking they're doing drugs
they're smoking weed they're playing
video games and they're not actually
improving right because you can do it
right you know this is sort of like a
fake statistic but it helps me when you
have Addiction in your family and your
life if you are the age you are minus
the amount of time you've been using
drugs like emotionally you can't develop
your frontal lobe if you're using drugs
consistently so it's like for me I I
wanted to make her really emotionally
immature yeah and kind of like just
annoying yeah yeah and it was just like
being having worked so hard to try to
not come off annoying in my in my real
life and desperate it was just like it
was so scary and uncomfortable were
there ever times when you were like Ugh
how do we give this note without I feel
like a little bit what I want I'll tell
you know it's interesting this is the
magic of editing too I think that you
this at your performance in this episode
more than anything required a kind of
because you're prone to digression you
as an actor you tried things that I
thought were inconsistent in the
performance it was oh yeah there were
things that I felt I had to carve out
and which is why I trusted you because
that when he's gonna know how to uh sew
this together I felt like yeah but I saw
again every day I saw that you wow you
also did things that I didn't imagine
and so that was a great part I said I
can use that I think I can get rid of
that and uh and I was trying to make her
kind of just like erratic and almost
emotionally dyslexic because that's how
Comics are we you know we laugh at
funerals and we cry at parties you know
so I was trying to also make her a
little bit emotionally dyslexic like
when things should have been you know uh
where you would think she would get
emotional she wouldn't and you know and
also making her very feral it was like I
was trying to be very uh uh you know in
the moment after you you've been
assaulted and you're alone what those
moments are like you know like going in
and out of just completely like
disassociating and going like that
didn't happen and then to also the
falling apart and we were on set you
know experimenting with like the
guttural sounds you make oh my God yeah
when you're just releasing anger right
you know so it's but it's the kind of
thing where it has to universally
resonate so it's like when you look at
something like that even though if you
know what the actor is doing if it's
something that's not going to land like
how do you make that decision like do is
it do you have like certain people that
you trust it's just like how does he
want or how does that how do you like
how do you decide with something that's
such a subjective emotional moment like
we did a shower scene that was like
afterwards that was like I think very
emotional and then we decided not to use
again yeah and it was like and I put it
in I took it out I put it I took it out
and then it really was it is a kind of
thing you just have to feel your way
through it felt like a cliche in a
strange way and I guess it was as simple
as that like I've seen it before and no
matter what you do it wasn't about how
we shot it uh it seemed like we we
needed it at the moment and um and then
it didn't I think everything that was
said was said in the private moment the
drive home and then to me there was that
shot through the door where you collapse
and my wife actually saw it and said I
can't believe she's replacing her uh she
she when she watched an early cut and
said I can't believe she's not just
taking her clothes off and taking a
shower I knew the shower scene was out
and
I was like oh no no I I I wanna this is
how I I like that very idiosyncratic
Brenda way of doing it that's
fascinating and so Rhythm I mean look
how do you know when what's Rhythm it's
like it's all you can't describe it and
then the hardest part is like as I'm
asking you this I'm asking to articulate
things that are so hard to articulate
you know it's like writing is rhythm the
writing is also writing is or I'd say
you know it's like what does someone
know why are they doing it's just like
just why are people behaving the way
they're behaving why are they saying
what they're saying like why is this
person saying that I mean you have to
ask that question you have to know it
right and then there's some things that
are just like I don't owe you the
explanation or there's no way I either
Believe it or I don't I just don't I
don't believe it right right I don't buy
it it doesn't matter right it's it's
authentic it's like why um and uh and it
can be surprising but it has to be
authentic I think that's something the
secret is how do you do something that's
not just chatbot gbt uh um consistent
emotionally consistent organic but I
always like I say it should be kind of
inevitable but surprising at the same
time right and then I think one of the
the biggest things is I see people
struggle with is when you work so hard
on something you've written it for a
year you produce it for a year you shoot
it and then to go like well this
shouldn't be in but we work so let's you
want to leave it in just because you've
worked so hard on it I think it's I
think I I actually have identified at
least my definition of one of the
definitions of Genius or the people who
actually compress the time between
trying something and recognizing it
doesn't work and making it not I mean
getting rid of it like you develop
quickly like I thought I needed this but
I just didn't the audience is never
going to miss something that they didn't
know was there in the first place yeah
but so many writers hold on to this and
go like but I worked so hard on that I
know well but you know I always think I
tell my kids as I said no matter how far
down the wrong path you are turn around
and then I think that being a comedian
it's like we're so not precious with
jokes because like I work in if it
doesn't hit it's gone I don't know how
like it worked on it you have to have
amnesia and and I was just talking to a
writer on the way over here who with
whom I'm I'm working uh Daniel Pearl
very closely on this particular show and
I go I really just love the fact that
you're you know you're you're you go our
egos are involved but then they're also
utterly uninvolved right right just have
to just like kind of uh Let It Go feel
the pain and just get rid of it at the
risk of stressing you out can I ask you
about the rape scene
so it's fascinating because I've done a
lot of sex scenes before and there's
always like a little bit of a like
you're kind of flirt there's you know
the the intimacy coordinators I have to
be honest over the last couple years
this is a new job where someone comes in
and they make sure a sex scene is you
know truly acting and they're you know
it's it's we joke because we go like
where did these people come from what
was your job before no industry because
when it's a new industry or like did
they just pull you from the marketing
department you know did a pilot with Lee
Daniels and the interesting coordinator
love you but you know she had gum and
hands she was like gum I was like this
is a fluffer this is not this is make
like you know and then you're sort of
trying to like make jokes with the
person you know a lot of times that
they've unionized other than other
mandatory but I'll always say like to
the person that I'm having the sex scene
with if you want to invite your
girlfriend or you know like there's
things you try to do to make it not just
turn into like a freebie hook up because
you're like but we're acting and we you
know and then there's always the joke of
like the guys like you know do I mean if
I get a boner it's not good but if I
don't that's even more insult you know
like there's and then I'm me so I'm
making jokes you know
um like you know if he's getting better
don't worry I'll just do my stand up and
get rid of it or whatever try to defuse
tension and awkwardness and this was the
first
um sex scene I've ever done it where it
felt like a stunt it felt like a stunt
I was pulled aside by uh uh the intimacy
coordinator because I was making jokes
to defuse any awkwardness you know like
be careful no I was basically like oh
because Sean who is plays the rapist by
the way fantastic my man to take the
risk to play a rapist in a show because
you cannot be you know people say like
you can't make no I have to really reach
out to him He's a brave because he
really he was terrific and you know that
his his wife now wife is a gynecologist
like he's uh like fights for women's
rights like on his own time I was like
wait you're actually a good person like
you know and so because these days gone
are the days where you can be a creep
and play a creep you know like when
people in comedy you know like you can't
make rape jokes anymore and it's like no
if you're a rapist you can't make Ravens
you know so now there's an onus now on
casting where you also have to hire
someone that is who wants to do it no I
can't does the right thing when no one's
watching too because then your show is
ruined if later the rapist there or if
someone plays a rapist and someone goes
like this person Davey in college and
they'll come forward because they don't
like right they don't like hiding in
plain sight etc etc so what he did was
just like so brave the fact that he took
this role and me I'm not not terrifying
to men you know just the idea that he
was like willing to do this and we got
to talk about you know because I'm come
off strong I come off tough I come off
hard to rape let's be honest and he was
willing to work with me on like maybe
there's just one thing that he this guy
does that's like a creepy Kink that
makes it clear that this is a lock step
thing he does a lot you know like we
were able to have this really tricky
conversation it was a private well the
intimacy coordinator sat with us and
Julie the director and then Sonic the
writer because I felt on some level you
know this is network television there's
only so much they're gonna be able to
show
uh like I want to show something that he
does like my first pitch was like a fish
hook like who died which is like a you
know something gross in the mouth like
that yeah and then it is so bizarre that
it makes her kind of freeze and
disassociate because it's so perverse
yeah instead of just Brute Force like
it's something that is his thing grabs
her earlobe something that where a
predator would want to stun his prey
yeah yeah and it's worked before that
would put her in a dissociative state to
make her stop fighting because we just
wanted to be so believable because she's
this like Groban foster care she's
probably been attacked many times why
wouldn't she fight hard or be screaming
we wanted to find something that would
disarm a really feral
you know person and walking through that
and so I'm making jokes and I'm like you
know maybe you know you know he chokes
her but I worry like um corner it's like
can you just um the jokes like it's just
we you know like just they're a little
far you know just while we're and I was
like oh no no I'm okay I just want you
to know I'm okay I'm the one getting I
was like and he's she's like no this is
murder protection
um
the men need to be protected too oh
there you go like that's kind of what
she was there for more you have to send
her flowers you know exactly because uh
I forgot like men are terrified right
now yeah and yeah I didn't it didn't
even occur to me oh yeah men need to be
protected from us on sets too thank you
for that reminder yeah yeah
that's great it was awesome no that's
awesome that sounds great and all the
things you're talking about were like so
are there uh um but anyway but we worked
for three days on that and we had two
stunt coordinators that were incredible
whereas normally you would just be like
working it out and like normally this is
my favorite things about sex scenes
before we had stunt coordinators helping
us it would just be like I use a hair it
would just be how you had sex like you
would both just do what you normally do
you're not like well this is how this
character has like you know what I'm
saying you would just do what you do so
it was so nice to have people come in
these two incredible stunt coordinators
that were helping us like I mean to the
to the to them we rehearsed so many
times it could not have been felt less
sexual when we were rehearsing it yeah
yeah yeah and because also there
shouldn't have been sexual chemistry or
energy sometimes like you kind of want
to do I mean this is gross to say as an
actor you know a lot of times you want
there to be you want there to be a
little chemistry so it's like I've been
on shows before comedies I'm not saying
this is right where you're kind of like
you're flirting there's some sexual
tension and then you want it to be in
the show you know and it captures this
great thing it's called chemistry right
but you don't want any sexual chemistry
in a rape scene you know yeah yeah so
it's like you know good thing Sean and I
felt super platonic right away but it
was we spent a bunch of time together
like hanging out kind of like becoming
platonic Bros in a way so that there was
never like anything by accident right
right totally totally very cool you know
so it was like it was but were you
scared like I mean just at a time where
I mean I'm going under sets and you know
totally well you know I scared but
there's also that part of me that I
think I'm a little masochistic I do like
walking into propellers I do like
offending I don't think I do it
intentionally but I kind of think I do
so I am 100 but you're one of the you're
you sound the alarm you're one of the
yeah I feel like I do Adam and I've made
some Terror I think I made some you know
mistakes creatively but I also feel like
when you're not doing that when you're
not provoking people and and triggering
them whatever words you want to use then
you're not doing your job then you're
just like wasting people's time and
you're bored and I think if you're born
it shows through being provocative like
if I'm not interested I like to make
things where I don't know the answer
that's right that's the only time I'm
interested is when so it's like the
thing so if you're afraid fear is a good
a good thing to feel you know that if
you're gut is saying I'm afraid of this
Jesus I'm gonna offend someone or by the
way happy to be wrong artists it's done
our job to be correct that's like I
think that's the politician's job and
the journalist job well Brenda's last
line is I don't know and that's the I
mean the I don't know is I think where
where I wish people today had uh well
shut the fuck up and say I don't know I
don't and by the way by the way when
someone says that how would you know
right we do we can't we don't know where
to rely on news we don't know what the
facts are how would you know right it
would be weird if you did but what if
everyone started every part every
conversation went into every day with
the humility of just shutting up and
listening and maybe uh that would be
great imagine if we actually learned how
to agree to disagree or respectfully uh
respect another person's opinion or can
I ask just if it's a human is a smart
person that I admire where do you get
your news like do you well I have to
tell you something I've responded but
with like I
I don't even know what's the big what's
the uh what's the diet what's the diet I
was I played tennis with these four four
guys on Sundays and they were talking
about
um oh something what's the big uh the
the drug that makes people stop eating
oh zombie I didn't even know what his
epic was and my friends were like are
you where have you been making the most
I think relevant television you also
have to sort of know what's going on and
know what is worth covering and what's
not and separating the noise from what's
actually happening um I you know if I
really I probably say BBC Al Jazeera
still in New York I'm still in New York
Times guy I mean I actually lost faith
for a bit yeah it's just sort of like
you know what pairs great with the
Ukrainian death count a new recipe for
avocado toast it's like the recipes and
I'll tell you and one thing that
actually troubles me a lot is that local
news was Once Upon a Time the way we
vetted our candidates was the way we and
and it's just been gutted by the
economic model so I'm worried that this
and again it's one of the themes that
courses through this show yep is that
this to me is the accelerant the the the
thing that is really eroding democracy
and thought and and uh and you know even
the idea of a Twitter the idea of it is
almost insulting like 140 words what can
you really say in 140 words unless
you're writing a haiku right right right
right you know the rain is falling it is
patterning it is nice I saw a hawk I
mean oh that's probably three syllables
too much as you can do yeah well I mean
it's sort of part of the de-evolution of
we used to be like
and then we you know developed our brain
and then got elegant and now we're back
to like
140 it's like sort of you know the the
visual of we evolved to stand up
straight and now we're evolving to hunch
over again you know without our phones
and stuff now we're going back to
grunting noises and 140 characters and
clubbing and clubbing each other over
the head with but with bones like the
opening of 2001. I mean we're kind of
there this is something that I think you
would appreciate ever since you're a TV
Titan you might find it funny that you
know uh networks now the new streaming
networks there's a new one there's 2B
there's Roku there's voodoo Hulu like
are you guys like literally it's just a
bunch of Apes animating like
Roku like it's just like we're just go
we're moving to sounds guttural noises
Google Google
are actual babies running Hollywood I'm
waiting for Butler to be on Fallon being
like my new show is on the Google
Network and tomorrow it airs on Gaga
like it's just sounds
right the first question
guys can we go back to words or and let
me ask Horizon I always want to know
exactly I'm missing for IMDb Network I
mean that's the other thing I mean
what's going on in television is just
like you know it's so much also it's so
it's so fragmented man we could probably
get more people with a sandwich board on
the corner of well that's the thing I
mean doing shows for Amazon we're
basically doing uh we're doing
television for a grocery store I mean it
is wild it really is we are do we are
and also and also what yeah it's true
we're basically window dressing on Saks
Fifth Avenue yeah and we are for Amazon
Prime and what's going to get really
interesting is you know I think and you
know people are like you know and I've
seen some of your press around doing you
know a show for Fox and I'm very proud
of doing a show for Fox uh you know and
I'm very mindful about you know who I
work for why how aligning with you but I
think it's easy to blame there's a
brilliant documentary called hillbilly
on Hulu
um which is also where accused airs
afterwards I would watch that because I
think that people just really want to
assign blame it's easy I mean let's be I
mean the hypocrisy was in Hollywood it's
like Americans are too smart for this
kind of show it's also like you know
Hollywood you know having some kind of
judgment about the murdochs or Fox and
then you make a movie called blonde
making money off of that and humanite
you know what I'm saying is like pick a
lane so it's like to me it's like this
has been such an exciting project
because
um number one I've heard none of the I
know stuff I was worried about as nor
have ions
I was bracing I totally was before I
sparkled my seatbelt and going like okay
let's see and nothing but incredibly
positive feedback from critics who are
notoriously looking looking for it no I
feel the same way and I was like wow I
again it's not over yet we'll see what
happens tonight we'll see I mean I
cannot wait for this episode but I think
it's just because you came in with the
show swinging this is going to be
entertaining it's gonna be provocative
and you showed that people are not
scared and you've showed that I think
people want to be entertained I mean you
know similarly when I go around the
country and I'm like can I not make this
joke about trans people can I make it
and people are so good grateful grateful
to let that you're going for it and not
playing it safe they're like if we don't
like it we'll let you know but play Just
well I think what you're saying is
exactly right I I've always said and
again I say it to I said the network is
I mean the audience is so smart they are
people are smarter than you think trust
me they want us to be brave they want us
to go for it and yes people are going to
have and there's going to be that and
again they're going to be the loud
mouths the people of the edges who just
again use this that's a good thing the
more upset people get the more you know
like that I don't see controversy as a
bad thing you know um last thing I'm
gonna ask a couple questions that I
always ask people that I'm gonna let you
go because I know how busy you are small
thing which is um as someone that hires
many people who's been a boss for a very
long time do you have any red flags in
people this is a little thing that I
like to pass on to the viewers it can be
anything from you know in you know you
haven't been in the dating field but if
you're dating someone and they ask you
to take they take a picture of their
food on a first date red flag in hiring
I find often someone that hasn't played
team sports red flag uh team sports
helpful I I when I hire it's always
people have been Waiters is a great
great thing great I think I think that's
a great that's a great thing but but
mostly it's listening yeah
it's it's actually
um
asking good questions it's a question I
mean there are no I mean I would say
team sports is a great um like when you
hire is there a question you ask that's
kind of like a sneaky cheat to know
someone's name let's have a conversation
I like to find out where people are from
I tend to I tend to discriminate against
people who who are privileged if you're
if you've had a lot you better be really
good and you better be really humble
like I I think it's arrogant you better
have been like cut out of the will you
kind of yep yeah pretty much I mean I I
gotta I have a real thing I I hate my
own kids I mean I have a really hard
time with my own kids uh good luck
getting a job if you're one of them but
no I really I I'm because you want to
put them through some almost like
intentional diversity jobs in high
school I sold shoes at athlete's foot
which is a terrible name oh my God you
work around naked that is so funny I
forgot about it but I had athlete's foot
when I was a kid the disease or the or
the or the story the disease uh from
playing basketball you just blew my mind
because I was I don't remember what I
was oh my last special I was writing
about making the argument that we're uh
safer than we've ever been the kids
safer than we've ever been even though
the phone
do you remember in Shoe Stores
um Married with Children was one of my
favorite shows growing up but there was
a shoe store in um in DC that had I
guess in the 50s they had an x-ray
machine where you would put your foot in
shoe stores of course and people that
worked at shoe stores got foot cancer
because they would just sit around and
do it all day yeah take pictures of
their videos it's crazy to think I know
I know while they were smoking crazy and
we're like but you should have almond
milk I mean just wild I miss coke coke
and hello well yes yes yes
I'll let you I've never done cocaine
before wow never done cocaine never done
Molly never done heroin but and I wanted
to in live podcasts like at 40 do
cocaine for the first time mushrooms
I've you know we did mushrooms on a live
podcast they don't do a time I think I
need to do baby I metabolize stuff
really fast I mean look everyone in La
is on drugs another thing I just learned
one of the Josh Kushner is starting a
health insurance company it's called
Oscar this is all true because I do
these corporate gigs and then I find out
all this crazy shit the cushions are
it's uh their big thing is three dollar
see because three dollar insurance three
dollar pills that's the thing their big
thing is Oscar Insurance three dollar
pills and at this corporate event he was
in it and I was doing all these roast
jokes and I did like guys three dollar
pills is not a good idea three dollar
pills uh is why we just lost and hash's
perfectly good Mini Cooper oh
too soon no too late too soon all of it
you know so it's like those are I said
it no yeah it's like the most offensive
insane joke you could probably make but
in this time where people are scared to
make jokes it just makes me want to go
so much harder
so much harder because it's like if
comedians are scared
we got to be very scared yeah I'm really
I'm encouraged by the way by your by
your intrepidness if that's a word it's
like maybe you need I mean there's how
can you do it any other way it's all you
know how to do but I think it's like but
I think our job is to kind of like
challenge authority in a good way not
just being like Punk brats but just
going like you know were the kids in
detention just to just to make sure
democracy is still strong and the first
amendment is still strong like we'll say
things we don't even believe you know
it's like just to make sure it can still
be said right you know because it's like
you know when people say you can't say
tranny you're like okay but what if the
joke is you know I used to say tranny
but now I have to say this what's the
comedy scene in Moscow
that's a really great question I don't
feel like it's robust I mean stand-up
comedy is actually uniquely an American
invention like there's the Court Jester
the tradition of that in order to
entertain them they weren't that funny
or they were delivering bad news they
were saying like hey the death count of
the war is this and trying to deliver
bad news in a silly way with bells but
like stand-up comedies you know in
America and immigrant coping mechanism
you know that started on the chitlin
circuit in America and uh in the
capitals of Jews I mean yeah from May
West up till it's only I mean stand-up
comedy it's really only 80 years old in
America so it's really not super popular
amazing it's incredible it's an American
art form uniquely American you know and
it is robust isn't it and I also think
everyone should do stand-up comedy at
some point because now with everyone's
job now you're gonna have to do some
kind of public speaking people are doing
their speeches on Zoom you know we're
moving more into customer service as
Things become more automated like public
speaking is something that is you know
really in terms of the survival of the
fittest is people that can you know
present because public speaking is um
they say the primordial reason that
everyone's so afraid of it is that uh
like your Reptilian Brain you know well
two thousand five thousand years ago if
you were speaking in front of a group it
meant you were defending yourself in
front of the tribe
essentially defending yourself of saying
I didn't do this I didn't kill and then
you were going to probably imminently
get stoned or killed so the nervousness
of you against the tribe which by the
way really quick can I say when you
walked past my robot you were not scared
no
usually men are terrified of it really
yes I found her kind of erotic and you
know the biological basis for fear of
robots no is it's called pathogen
avoidance because I built this robot for
my last special so I noticed that when
guys see a robot they're like like right
and when a girl sees that they're like
oh cool that's weird so it's pathogen
avoidance pathogen avoidance is how we
evolve to recoil at something that looks
sick or dead so that a man won't have
sex with it fantastic because if
something looks human but doesn't quite
move like a human are you telling me I'd
be comfortable having sex with the dead
thing I just feel I don't know what
you're saying no I just that would mean
I guess your ancestors didn't didn't
fuck corpses and I think you should be
proud of that you know they fucked
robots safe they did but I hate I loved
ex machina one of my favorite movies uh
so brilliant so good and another thing I
was just reading about how um the deeper
said our eyes are the more our ancestors
were punched in the face
really So based on how oh because they
were like uh yeah uh because that
protected you from yeah so the deeper
set your eyes are the more your
ancestors were punks so we're asking for
it and you didn't recoil it the robot
your eyes look like they're you know not
too deep set so it's like your ancestors
are right a little but we did a little
hitting let's get a little bit of yeah
yes and then the last last thing just
because of um who you are and I just
want um your Insight on this especially
with the first episode back with the
checklist episode uh addressing you know
School shooters and just going for the
most the scariest topic as a father what
are the things that you are
the most worried about with this next
Generation you said phones well I'm
things that as an alarm Sounder like the
the show like it's the job of young
people to be hopeful and I think that I
grew up in a world where even though I
had my trauma and you had yours I think
both of us recognized that we're in a
world where things seem to be trending
and the The Hope felt a little more
abundant out there like um we were
um and now I just think there's a lot of
I think all the assumptions of our world
although the world order I think again
civilian the lack of kindness the lack
of of uh of um I mean the fact that Tip
O'Neill and Robert and you know and and
Teddy Kennedy could bunk together you
know again the idea now that that people
from you know both sides of the aisle
are trying to kill each other
um and that's a political thing but I
think it's a simple but was it not
always like that you know it probably
was more like it than than uh than um uh
I care to admit but I'm trying to think
what's the big thing because it's also
like my thing is I always wonder if
things have always been the same they
just look different or things have
always been like this we just never had
proof of it so it's like cancer like
Cancers and all time high it's like 100
years ago we had no way to diagnose it
so it was very hard to be this meat
puppet looking at the universe and
trying to like really offer anything
other than anecdotal or feeling eyes at
a time I can't separate is at a time of
life is it because I'm a 61 year old
male uh who's losing his memory very
quickly
um um you know whose joints hurt and who
is feeling a little out of step with the
world what's encouraging is I meet young
people and they're tuned to a frequency
that I that I am not tuned to so they're
on Adderall I guess they are but but
they're but uh but there are some
remarkable um so I'm I'm such a hopeful
person and I'm just reflecting my own
slight hopelessness sometimes which I've
never felt before in a way that I feel
now but I think it also is hard as I get
older too is like when watching the
pandemic of people going like well these
kids are in the masks and this is so bad
for them and they need to go out and
play and socialize and they shouldn't be
in mass and you're like yeah we want
every generation that after us to have
the childhood we had but they might be
preparing for the world they're gonna
live I think that's right I think that's
hard to go like it you can't apply again
once again you can't maybe they should
get used to wearing performance when I
say past performance doesn't uh
guarantee future
um in a financial document you know past
performance guarantee future results or
something right right yeah my business
manager says that and I'm right I don't
read my own stolen from yeah that's what
that's what someone says when they're
stealing from you past performance is
not you should have read uh I told what
I said it's like I never got past like I
couldn't read my own contracts I gotta
get I get so bored don't you like myself
it's like I've never gone I'd rather you
steal from me than me have to read this
document I feel the same like really
because you're stealing my time either
way I'd rather you steal my money than
my time yeah yeah I'm I'm there too and
then um uh last night
I probably way less worried than most
people because I think you've seen that
and I'm really happy to see that because
I believe in like survival of the
fittest this always happens you know
people like kids with it people have
anxiety disorders we're supposed to be
anxious we're designed to be anxious I
think it's survival of the most anxious
it'd be weird if people weren't anxious
you know I think I'm more worried about
our Mass Reliance on big Pharma to solve
emotional problems when we should just
be developing the tolerance for
discomfort yeah I think that uh everyone
you know not everyone but parents you
know I'm gonna say over coddling their
kid is really cool that concerns me too
the kids that I see that are struggling
the most are the ones that have the
least amount of adversity but you can't
intentionally inflict diversity on your
kid I had a trauma but but how do we but
I guess for me I I am grateful for my
own trauma I was talking to sonay about
I call it trauma privilege it is it's
like weird because it is who you are and
like you'd have to really like have to
there's a resilience there's that I mean
look you also have to you know I've been
in 10 years of a 12-step program called
ACA adult children of alcohol Alex you
know which is you know not scrappling
with substance abuse but grappling with
the effects of growing up around
alcoholism which is uh you know
perfectionism addiction control
addiction workaholism you know uh
defining yourself through your
productivity that sort of well and
that's and that's a great question too
because I I was just a believer in work
till you you know if you don't come out
on Sunday don't bother coming in Monday
I just I I was that person it was
punishing it was really punishing I know
that it but it was all I knew but I also
enjoy at work you know I think when
people over pathologize me like you work
too much and I'm like you work too
little I also love what I do most people
don't get to love what they do so I
think that like you know love what you
do you won't work a day in your life
kind of thing so I Like You Know It's
tricky because with my workaholism which
by the way I did go to Workaholics
Anonymous meeting once and this was when
I had two shows on the air you know you
know it's like you can't not be a
workaholic when you're running shows you
are working 24 times but the moment
happens when the machine does break I
mean I was on the reason I fell in love
with Spain is because I just or went to
Spain is because I was under the table
rocking doing four shows at the same
time I can't you know do it and someone
who's prone to sort of be moth to the
flame has to monitor it somewhat so I do
admire these this generation which seems
um to recognize there are I don't know
they'll figure it out but you basically
kind of hit a point where you said I
need to I just spend more time spend
time in Europe well I had to be out of
the time zone I like I I literally it
had to be as prosaic as just being where
everybody who could bother you was
asleep that's when I went to the
Maldives which I was really reluctant to
go I was in post-production on a movie
editing I went and it was the most
relaxing thing ever because when I was
awake everyone else was asleep and I
went you have to just get off the time
zone the time Zone's everything it
doesn't matter we're most work done I if
I really need to work on like a new
special or work or study like when I was
studying the Brenda stuff to try to get
in it would start at midnight and work
till four in the morning because
everyone else was asleep and it's the
only time I could have a singular focus
and not even if you're not on your phone
you're thinking ugh in an hour when I
check my phone I'm gonna have 50
messages like it's it's taking up
bandwidth even and yep yep and used to
be planes but now freaking the dorks
that put Wi-Fi on planes you losers I
know and you know when I was walking
endlessly it was like really like the
opening scene in Severance like through
the airport like you have to walk about
six or seven miles to get to the street
I was in a I was in this because they
were doing construction but I passed a
Wi-Fi you know how long Wi-Fi's been on
plane how long has it been yeah well
Louise had that's a brilliant joke about
it it's 15 years it's been like it's
been like 2000 but it's worked for about
six months
do you ever watch it like it just goes
like this far and it never goes further
It's tricky because and then well you
spend the first hour of the flight
getting on Wi-Fi and then you start
Landing you know how many times have you
look at that Circle like I want to know
the spinning wheel of does the spinning
wheel like Spinning Wheel of death
commercial it really is uh what is the
um it's the Skinner what's the skitter
box like that's what it feels like at
this point you're like I don't even know
what I'm doing this for
um but I also Louis CK had that
brilliant incredibly incisive uh uh joke
of 15 years ago I think he did it on
Conan about when uh Wi-Fi first started
uh being on planes uh uh they were like
Wi-Fi's on planes I was like oh my God
there's Wi-Fi and someone logged in and
then like five minutes later cut off and
the guy went out it's just bullshit he's
like a miracle habit and then within
five minutes oh we're so you were so
entitled that it was taken away because
do you realize we are flying it through
thirty thousand chair in the sky
brilliant last last the same way I like
to ask
F's where they eat where do great uh I
would love to know how great
entertainers are entertained what do you
watch
do you want have you watched anything
recently that you loved I'm I'm actually
watching uh Better Call Saul for the
first time
and I in fact I was on a plane racing uh
and I and I and Vince is someone an old
friend and I've known him for a long
time and I I landed and texted him and I
said I'm burning my writer's Guild card
because it was so shorthand it was so
good
um I'm I'm actually not a consumer it's
it I either get angry so hard I get
angry or jealous nothing good happens me
too people won't even watch TV with me
because I'm like that's ADR that was
Loop oh I auditioned for that I should
have done it like do you know what I
mean it was like it's so but there are
certain times where I can be entertained
by something I was entertained by by a
palm tree in swing in the wind I was
sitting on my de on my patio and
watching this palm tree my my son came
up 18 goes what are you doing so you are
on mushrooms
I was smoking a cigar and I was watching
this what are you doing I'm just
watching that palm tree he goes well how
long have you been doing it I said about
20 minutes and he and he just shook his
head and walked away but that was
entertaining to me I don't know that was
the reason I never have had before the
um because you didn't have to deal with
giving uh no it's to an actor okay I'm
actually a visual artist for the first
time in my life I've had the the
composure to really appreciate visual or
things that words don't do that sure
words get in the way of communication I
think at this point I will say one thing
my favorite show on TV is Apple screen
savers oh fantastic oh the jellyfish
you're just watching the jellyfish go
and you are they real they're not the
Ariel just watching the algae I think it
is I mean we'll see that's where we're
in the we're in the jumbo dry as my
favorite philosopher we're in this like
this John beaudgerard the simulacra of
like you know now when we look at
something incredible we assume it's fake
and what's it called the uh what's it
called the robot the um oh god with um
uncanny valley yeah yeah when you look
at something it's like the idea of of
that we actually prefer the artifice to
the real I.E you know the Paris Las
Vegas like the Eiffel Tower Las Vegas we
prefer to the actual life for Tower like
we prefer runs to actual fruit at this
point so it's sort of like do we even
care if it's real or not fake tits
whatever you know it's like right same
same but the uh watching the Apple
screen savers I sort of I decide they're
real because that's my hopeful magic I
would I want this to be real yeah but
they probably do go in and clean it up I
don't know I'm going back and reading
the old stuff and turning it's wonderful
to sort of actually read the things I
was supposed to read that you pretended
to read the first 10 pages up and now
reading it is actually I also like it's
kind of fascinating to go through like
the art this is I did a pilot um at
Amazon with Lee Daniels about this and
about a college campus ombudsman's
office and how the college students were
trying to like cancel I like Rembrandt
was uh you know he was a rapist and he
painted these naked women it was male
gays and like when do you can you
separate the art and the artist I
believe artists should be perverts they
should be sickos Neil labute is hands
down my favorite uh playwright of all
time and then when people like he made
us uncomfortable in acting class I'm
like yeah no sh his plays make me
uncomfortable when I'm reading them
alone in my house you know what I mean
so it's like I think that we're at this
time where artists like you know it's
our job to be dangerous but we can't be
a danger to the people we work with so
how do we protect ourselves and each
other so we can still you know be doing
things that are dangerous and feel real
without hurting people or getting you
you just said you answered my question
the question you asked me and that's the
question I worry about which is that uh
is that that very thing the sort of
entitlement because the people like you
stop being brave were in trouble well
it's getting harder and harder is the
truth I think now at the same time I
appreciate that being poked and prodded
and challenged and I think there are a
lot of things to question about our past
and then I would say just put it in the
show so what I do is when I get when I
get when I have someone say you can't
say Merry Christmas I got in trouble
instead of Roseanne say Merry Christmas
I just go great I'm gonna write a joke
about it I'm gonna go on Leno or Fallon
and talk about it because there's
everyone has in their workplace a
version of this even though if they're
not you know running the show Roseanne
at Chipotle wherever they work they've
had a situation where they said nice
shirt and got in trouble like everyone
can relate yeah absolutely and we're a
little bit uh we're you know we're a
little bit Shell Shocked I am and I
appreciate again no I remember we I was
and I hope that you know Phil called out
when we were in um we were both kind of
zombies in New York when we were doing
like five was that was technically up
fronts kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it was kind of like the first time you
and I had really like met in person and
this has happened a lot where we were on
the Press line like posing and you were
behind me and I put my hand like behind
you and you put your hand behind me and
I kind of hovered my hand behind you and
you we both hovered our hands and then
we grabbed it was just like this you can
touch my back like it was just like this
Awkward Moment where we were both afraid
to touch each other's lower back in a
photo we grabbed it then you made me
feel that was better I'm like because
then I just go like do you guys think I
have time to sue any of you I'm a female
comic like hugging someone at upfronts
doesn't break my top 99 uh things with
men yeah yeah in this business I'm gonna
give you one little present
this is for you from me
um thank you for believing in me thank
you for um having me on a brilliant
brilliant show I'm so honored
um that you took a chance on me
what a pleasure pull it out can you tell
me that is Brenda's necklace you are man
in the show one of the many one of the
many wow I didn't give you we had we had
a choker on her because the thing is
with chokers is that sends a message to
men like yeah
I feel like now it's my halo
thank you so much
thank you so much for coming and these
very awkwardly accused
um absolutely brilliant show and what I
will say is the roughest toughest
hardest to crack guys I know are
watching the show and calling me and
saying this totally brought me to tears
that this totally changed the way I see
this like people are saying this like
totally changed the way I think about
this and I think that is like the
greatest Testament
um to a great piece of art especially of
this day and age where it's so hard to
change people's minds yes
or open them thank you I love you thank
you love you don't ride elephants guys
goodbye thank you
[Music]
foreign